during the transaction of data and
information between multiple devices the
task of establishing maintaining and the
sharing of data is handed over to the
network model which also governs the
protocols enacted on the transmitted
data hi guys and welcome to yet another
interesting video as simply learn
but before we begin if you love watching
tech videos subscribe to our channel and
hit the bell icon to never miss an
update from us
let's take a look at the agenda for
today's session
for today's session firstly we'll
understand what exactly is the tcp ip
model continuing with the protocols that
are applied
the layer structure in the tcp and ip
model
then we'll see the benefits of using tcp
model
and comparison between osi model and
tcpip model
let's begin
firstly we'll understand what exactly is
the model
the tcp model is a method of sharing
data and information over the
communication channel
where the data has to go through each of
the four layer structure of the network
model
where it also performs tasks such as
remodeling of data efficient
transmission and air related issues
each layer has dedicated protocols that
they enact on the transmission data
now let's continue with the protocols
that are used in the tcp model
to understand the protocols that are
used in the tcpip model we'll compare it
with the osi model and if you want to
know more about the osi model you can
visit our video on the simply learn
channel
let's begin
the top most three layers of the osi
model which are application layer
presentation layer and session layer
collectively refers to the application
layer in the tcbip model
where they use
protocols such as ftp file transfer
protocol http hypertext transfer
protocol telnet and smtp which is simple
mail transfer protocol
then we have the transport layer from
osm model which refers to the transport
layer in the tcp model
where they apply protocols such as tcp
transmission control protocol and udp
user datagram protocol
moving on we have network layer
from the osi model which refers to the
internet layer in the tcpip model
which apply protocols such as ip
internet protocol icmp internet control
message protocol and arp
address resolution protocol
then we have data link layer and
physical layer from the osm model which
refer to the network access layer in the
tcp model
this layer doesn't exactly apply any
protocol but are connected through
physical medium which includes ethernet
wi-fi
and cables
now that we are completed with the
protocols regarding tcp model let's take
a look at the layers in detail
the tcvip network model consists of
different layers
where the original model consists of
four different layers which are
application layer transport layer
internet layer and network access layer
then we have the updated model which
consists of layer
application layer transport layer
internet layer data link layer and
physical layer
let's take a look at the layers in
detail
the first layer that we are going to
know about is the application layer
application layer
this layer acts as an interface between
the application and programs that
require the tcp model for communication
including tasks performed by the layer
such as data representation for the
software application that are executed
by the user and then forward it to the
transport layer
the protocol supplied by this layers are
http hypertext transfer protocol which
is used to access information available
on the internet
then we have smtp simple mail transfer
protocol which is used to access email
related tasks
moving forward we have the transport
layer
this layer is responsible for
establishing connection between the
sender and the receiver device
this layer performed the task of
dividing the data from the application
layer into packets
where they are used to create sequences
which are then transferred over to the
destination device it also performs the
task of maintaining the data that is to
be transmitted without error and
controls the data flow rate
the protocols that are applied in the
transport layer are
tcp transmission control protocol which
is responsible for transmission of
segments over the communication channel
then we have udp user datagram protocol
which is responsible for identifying
error in the data that is to be
transmitted over the communication
channel
moving forward the next layer is the
internet layer
this layer is responsible for the
transmission of data over the network
channel that is they provide a proper
route for the packets to be transferred
over the communication channel
the protocols that are applied by this
internet layer are
iprotocol which is the internet protocol
this protocol assigns a unique address
to a physical system
so that it can be identified on the
internet
then we have arp
address resolution protocol
this protocol is used to find the
physical address of the system using the
internet protocol address
in the end we have the network access
layer this layer is a combination of
data link layer and physical layer from
the usm model
where it is responsible for maintaining
the task of sending and receiving data
in drawbits
the raw bits are transferred from the
center side to the receiver side in the
format of binary digit which are zeros
and ones
let's move on with the advantages of
using the tcp ip model
the tcp model assigns an ip address to
each of the system that is available on
the network channel so that they can be
identified on the internet
then they are also responsible for
enacting different protocols on the data
that is to be transmitted over the
communication channel the tcp model also
enables the user and the system to
access different format of data over the
communication channel
now let's take a look at the last topic
for this session which is the osm model
versus the tcp model
on comparing both of the network models
we get
the osi model consists of seven
different layers whereas the tcp model
comprises of four different layers
the osi model has separate session layer
presentation layer whereas the tcpip
model comprises of a single application
layer
the transport layer in the osi model
provides packet delivery protocols
but in the tcp model transport layer
does not provide any such protocols
the osm model is implemented during
network communication
but in case of tcp model it is used as a
reference model for the network channel
with this we have reached the end of the
module
if you have any questions regarding the
topic you can ask them in the comment
section below
thank you for watching
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here